[موسيقى]
انا اسمي غاده صعبه اردنيه مسيحيه بنت من
ثلاث بنات لعائله لم تنجب غيرهن الضررت
بعد وفاه اختي شقيقتي الغير متزوجه بحصر
الارث وخاصه انه ما في اخ يحجب وقانون
القرد المتبع في كنائسنا في الاردن يعتمد
على الشريعه الاسلاميه وقواعدها الفقهيه
[موسيقى]
لست انا فقط من تضرر من هذا الموضوع هناك
العشرات غيري اللواتي اليوم وكل يوم
يتضررنا ويقعنا ضحيه لعدم تغيير القانون
مثل اموريم وبناتها الثلاث فبعد وفاه
زوجها عانت السيده في ميراث زوجها وحفظ حق
بناتها فيه لتامين مستقبلهن ام ريم تعيش
في مدينه الحصن شمال الاردن توجهنا لها
لنعرف التفاصيل زوجي هو من نفس العيله
اقارب يعني في 94 تعرفنا مزبوط على بعض
وتزوجنا
طبعا
خلفنا ثلاث صبايا
كبروا صبايا كبروا البنات
بتعرفي كيف انا وياه منشتغل انا كنت في
الخدمات الطبيه وهو كمان كان يشتغل في
الاثار فكنا نحط القرش على القرش يعني
تنصير قررنا انه ناخذ قرض
ونشتري هذا البيت اذا سكنا هنا في البيت
تقريبا عشر ايام
شكى من صدره
نقلنا على المستشفى من ضمن الفحوصات اللي
عملها طلع عنده كانسر منتشر هو نفسه شاف
حاله تعبان
بحكي لي نادي لي ريم عن بنته الكبيره
فناديت فيه بحكي لها بابا
جيبي كاتب العدل وجيبي المحامي انا راح
اتنزل لكم على البيوت اطول لكم البيوت
اجا كاتبه فعلا يوم الاحد الصبح
الساعه 12 وشوي بالليل يعني احد على اثنين
توفى مالحه
فهنا سقطت الوكاله
انا ما بلوم لاشخاص
ولا بدين اشخاص
انا عتباني على القانون
عتباني على القانون اللي مش انا بس
ناس كثير مثلي
يعني انا بعد ما توفى خليل عرفت انه في
قضايا كثير عمرها ما خطرت لي ولا عمري
فكرت نهائيا احنا بنتكلم في الكنائس
بنتطلب بالكنائس نتعمد بالكنائس
يعني ماشيين على القانون وماشيين على
وصايا الرب صح ولا لا ايش معنى
هاي الشغله شغله الارث احنا مش قادرين
نحصلها
[موسيقى]
بدانا البحث والتحري لنعرف اين نحن اليوم
من تعديل قانون الارث المسيحي
[موسيقى]
لم تتغير الاحوال الشخصيه منذ نشا الاردن
الحديث عام
1921 رغم تعديل قانون الطوائف المسيحيه
مرتين خلال القرن الماضي الاول عام
1938 تحت اسمي قانون الطوائف غير المسلمه
رقم اثنين وفي التعديل الثاني في عام 2014
استبدل المشرع قانون الطوائف غير المسلمه
بقانون الطوائف المسيحيه مع تعديلات غير
جوهريه فيما يتصل بالميراث
[موسيقى]
الرحله لم تكن سهله وخاصه ان المجتمع
الاردني متحافظ في الحديث عن فكره تعديل
قانون الارث الذي يحمل في طياته الكثير من
تفاصيل امتلاك اراض واملاك تاريخيه تخص
عشائر وعائلات كبيره اغلب المتضررين من
عدم تعديل القانون رفض ان يتكلم امام
الكاميرا وان يكشف عن هويته حاولنا
التواصل من خلال الاب بسام شحاتيت رئيس
محكمه الروم الارثوذكس مع اكبر عدد منهم
حضرتك
مخاوف لما بعد عمر طويل يصير
شو
حجم لا بس يا دكتور يا دكتور بده يكون عند
الواحد الشجاعه يوقف ويحكي امام الكاميرا
[موسيقى]
لا لا ما راح تطلعي
رح يتغطى الصوت والوجه الكاميرا راح تكون
بظهرك ما رح تشوفي كاميرا
كنت اول وحده بخواتي بكمل المدرسه يعني
وانا لسه عند اهلي
جبت الحمد لله معدل عالي ودخل جامعه
داومنا بالجامعه يوم احد ابوي توفى يوم
الخميس يعني اصلا كانت صدمه لنا انه يعني
لان احنا ما كان النا معين لا امي بتشتغل
انا لسه سنه اولى جامعه واختي بدها تدخل
جامعه ومشيت الحياه تقريبا سنه واحنا ولا
واحد فيهم من اعمام يتعرف علينا بقرش هلا
بهاي الفتره صارت مشكله
الميراث والتقسيم حصر الارث لانه كان كل
اشي لسه باسم الاب واسم جدي بس كان مشاعر
ما كان مقسم
بسبب انه ما في عنا اخوان وفاه الاب صار
الاب اللي هو جدي وعمامي كلهم انهم ياخدوا
بالورثه
واغلب الحصه كان المفروض لجدتي تروح
حاولنا معه مره ومرتين وثلاثه على الفاضي
ما كان في نتيجه وطبعا اعمامي كانوا ضد
انه جدي يتنازل لانه بالاخير راح يطلع لهم
منه
يعني باخر اشي يعني دخلنا كاهن من الكنيسه
طلع وحكى معه بانه بالتفاصيل وانه بنات
وكذا لحتى تنازل هل هو فعليا تنازل على
الورق
لكن اللي صار بعد هيك ان التنازل اللي على
الورق ما ريحنا من كل هاي القصص
يعني بلش مشي موضوع قولي جدي مش الموضوع
وتنازل بلشوا اعمامي صاروا يرنوا علينا
تليفونات طبعا مع مسبات وغلط انه تنازلوا
ساعه تنازلوا بدون مصاري ساعه انه احنا
اولادنا اولى من انه يكون في نسايب يروح
لهم المصاري
مرت تنازلوا مثلا بالبيت بس ضلكم بالبيت
[موسيقى]
فشلت محاولات واصلاحيين للمساواه الجندريه
لمصلحه المراه المسيحيه والتعديل الابرز
في قانون 2014 يسمح لرؤساء الطوائف باصدار
قانون خاص باتباع كنائسهم بما في ذلك
المساواه في الميراث حسب ما تم توضيحه من
اشخاص ذوي اختصاص بالاحوال الشخصيه لدى
المسيحيين
بموضوع الارث في الاردن مهم جدا ان نتطرق
الى الارث من الناحيه المسيحيه في الكتاب
المقدس هناك مسواه بالارث ومن هذا المبدا
ايضا الكنيسه والقوانين الكنسيه استوحت
فكره المساواه
ففي قسم مجموعه قوانين الكنائس الشرقيه في
المؤمنون بالمسيح بتحدث القانون 11 عن
المساواه كل انسان اعتمد ودخل واصبح عضو
في الكنيسه هناك مساواه في الكرامه والعمل
للذكر والانثى ومن هذا المنطلق نجد ان
فكره المساواه موجوده في الكنيسه وفي
اللاهوت وفي القانون المسيحي نجد كثير من
النساء في القديم كانوا يحرم من الميراث
وايضا لا يعطوا حتى النصف فكانت تعطى مبلغ
بسيط وتتنازل عن حقها
[موسيقى]
هناك بعض التحديات التي تعاني منها المراه
المسيحيه فعلى سبيل المثال عدم تقبل فكره
الانصبه الارثيه المتساويه بين الذكور
والاناث وقد يكون السبب في ذلك
الموروث الاجتماعي السائد التخبط بين فكره
الموروث الاجتماعي السائد والانتماء
الديني هاد بيعمل نوع من الاشكاليه في
المجتمع المسيحي لكن قله من الناس هي التي
يعني تنظر للموضوع بهاي الطريقه في
الديانه المسيحيه ما في قوانين واضحه
وصريحه تتعلق بموضوع الارث لكن السبب
الرئيسي لتطبيق
الشريعه
الشريعه الاسلاميه
وقواعدها الفقهيه في عمليه تقسيم الارث في
المسيحيه هو ما جاء في الماده 1686 من
القانون المدني والتي تنص على انه يطبق
احكام الشريعه الاسلاميه على جميع
الاردنيين فيما يتعلق بالميراث فهي حكت
على جميع الاردنيين ما وضحت انه سواء كان
مسيحي او مسلم فمن هذا المنطلق انه بلشنا
نطبق احكام الشريعه الاسلاميه
في المسيحيه
[موسيقى]
ربطت الحكومه التعديل باجماع الكنائس على
مسوده قانون مشترك قبل عرضه على مجلس
النواب وذلك اعتمادا على المواد الموجوده
في الدستور قانون يجب ان يذهب في مراحل
عده احنا في البدايات كنا بنحاول ان ناتي
بقانون وكان هناك جهد كبير من الكثير من
الناس
المختصين من محامين من كهنه
من اعضاء في الكنيسه لي بلوره هذا القانون
وتم بلوره نسخه جيده جدا في هذا المجال
واليوم يجب ان يتوافق عليها مجلس الكنائس
ومن ثم ان تذهب في القنوات التشريعيه
الصحيحه حتى الان القانون لم يذهب في
القنوات التشريحيه الصحيحه وما زال
باعتقادي عن مجلس الكنائس ممكن والذي
بدوره عليه واجب اليوم ان يتجه بسرعه بهذا
الاتجاه
[موسيقى]
90% اذا مش 99% من المسيحيين في هذا
الكلام لكن واضح ان هناك البعض وقد تكون
لقضايا ماليه وقد تكون لقضايا تتعلق بانه
يعني لا يريد ان تخرج او ان يخرج
الميراث خارج حلقه معينه وبالتالي
يعارضوا هذا القانون لكن انا اعتقد انه
علينا ان نعمل بهذا الاتجاه وسن القانون
واضح بهذا الخصوص وهو قانون يخص
المسيحيين الاردني فقط ولا يخص كل
المواطنين الاردني
[موسيقى]
في الواقع انه نتذكر انه الاردن لا عنا
مقام بتعديل الدستور اول مره ب 2011 كان
احدى التعديلات المهمه فيما يتعلق بقانون
الطوائف المسيحيه صدر قانون الطوائف
المسيحيه ب 2014 واللي تطلب انه يصير في
تغيرات فيما يتعلق باختيار القضاه وايضا
موضوع الرسوم وغيره فوجدنا انه هناك
معاناه لدى الاسره المسيحيه وبالذات لدى
المراه المسيحيه والطفل المسيحي في امور
تتعلق بالاحوال الشخصيه خاصه عندما نقارن
مع الاحوال الشخصيه للمسلمين لان هناك
تطوير مستمر في قانون الاحوال الشخصيه
للمسلمين فوجدنا انه لا بد من اطلاق
مبادره سميت محاميات نحو التغيير كانت
تهدف الى تطوير القوانين الكنسيه فيما
يتعلق بالاحوال الشخصيه
[موسيقى]
تاسست الجمعيه عام 1950
وهي الجمعيه الوحيده في الاردن التي تعنى
بشؤون المراه المسيحيه لهيك بتلاقينا احنا
اي مبادرات تدعم المراه المسيحيه وقضاياها
بندعمها زي مبادره محاميات نحو التغيير
انت شفتي قديش حاولنا نستقطب ناس يطلعوا
يحكوا
لكن للاسف بخافوا لانهم راح يتاذوا
اجتماعيا
وكثير في حالات احنا بنسمع فيها وبيجونا
وبحكوا بالموضوع خاصه لما يكون في بنات
بالعائله بدخل عليهم مثلا اعمامهم اولاد
اعمامهم بيستفيدوا من ميراث الاب وفي كثير
قضايا منها اخر قضيه سمعناها انه السيده
وبناتها صاروا يدفعوا اجره المنزل اللي هو
لابوهم يدفعوا الاعمامهم هذا مثال كبير
جدا للي عم بيصير عنا ولهيك احنا عم نطالب
بحق لكل مواطن اردني مسيحي انه يكون عنا
قانون كنسي ينصف المراه المسي موضوعنا هون
صار انه طب انا ليش اعطي حصتي مثلا لابن
عمي او اعطي حصتي لبنت عمي وهي رح تروح مع
شخص تاني صف الموضوع نفسه فانا ليش انحرم
ورده ابوي ليش ما انا انبسط فيها استمتع
فيها احافظ عليها احافظ على اسم ابوي زيي
زي اي شب يعني هلا صار ما في ما في فرق
والمشكله انه صرنا بالالفين لسه منعاني من
هذه الظاهره ومنعاني من هاي المشكله ما عم
تتغير صار في مفاوضات على الاراضي صار في
حاولوا يوقعونا صاروا يروحوا على منطقه
معينه مسؤوله عن العقارات هاي حتى يحاولوا
يقيموا اسمنا من الموضوع بحجه انه احنا مش
موجودين او بحجه انه احنا مسافرين طبعا
بيشتغلوا
بالدائره الاراضي كانوا كتير واعيين او
مارق عليهم كثير قصص كانوا يرفضوا يصير اي
اشي الا بحضور هدول الاشخاص اللي هم احنا
يقدر عدد مسيحي الاردن بمئتين وتسعه
وثلاثين الف فرد بحسب احصائيه صدرت عام
2015 من المعهد الملكي للدراسات الدينيه
اي ما يعادل اكثر من اثنين في المئه من
عدد السكان
تنقسم الطوائف المسيحيه في الاردن الى
الروم الارثوذكس واللتين والكاثوليك
والبروتستانت هذا الموضوع كله بقودنا انه
في الاردن احنا للان عم نحاول نطلع قانون
يساوي بين الرجل والمراه ونحل مشاكل الناس
اللي بيعانوا منها قاعدين عائلات كثيره
وما في صدى كان بالماضي لكن الان استطعنا
الحمد لله ان نضع هذا على الطاوله ونضع
امام المسؤولين ونضع امام مجلس النواب
ومجلس الاعيان وان ان يصبح هذا الموضوع
موضوع نقاش وهو المطلوب الان ان يصبح
موضوع فيما بعد الى اصدار تعليمات او
قانون او خاص فيما يخص الارث وفيما يخص
المحاكم الكنسيه لتتبعوا الى ان الوصول
الى انه العدل والمساواه بين جميع افراد
المجتمع الاردني هلا
التعديلات المطالبها ان البنت تحجب الارث
بمعنى انه اللي عنده بنات بنات وبرسوه
بدخلش اطراف اخرى على على الارث وبياخذوا
حصصهم ويصبحوا هم ولاجئين في بيوتهم
بدفعوا اجر
الصحيح انه احنا عم نعاني من موضوع الارث
انا بشكل شخصي كونه عندي ثلاث بنات
عم بعاني بموضوع الارث حاولنا جهدنا انه
القانون الحالي الموجود هو ما بينصفنا
حاولنا مع عده جهات وعده امور لنوصل لحل
ما في حل الا انه نسجل مباشره باسامي
البنات وهذا اللي عم نحاول نعمله وعملنا
جزء منيح منه وعم نكمل بالباقي بس
بالنهايه هذا مش حل مش حل نهائي لكل
العائلات
كل التفاصيل اللي ممكن يتعرضوا لها حته
يعني بحكي لهم يعني اذا صار اشي الي ولا
لابوكم ممنوع توقعوا على اي ورقه بدون ما
انتم تكونوا حامين حالكم يعني لو وجود
محامي اذا انتم مش عارفين بتجيبوا محامي
او بتستعينوا بحدا بخوالكم بعمكم المهم ما
بتوقعوا على اي اشي الا يكون بناء على
تفاصيل معينه انكم تقدروا توقعوا عليها
المعطل الاساسي هو الفكر العشائري وانا
بقول للاخوان كلهم لما بناقشهم في هذا
الموضوع بقول له انت لما بتعطي بنتك مش
جوز بنتك فيجب هذا هذا المفهوم ان يكون في
عقلك انه انا لما بعطي بنتي يعني لما بنتك
بتكون عندك في البيت ما هي بتكون معززه
مكرمه ليش لما بتطلع من البيت وتبطل معجزه
مكرمه بطل انت بدك تعطيها وتعطي اخوها
من يعترض على تعديل قانون الارث المسيحي
في الاردن يبرر رايه بان الاردني المسيحي
جزء لا يتجزا من النسيج الاردني ولا يجب
ان يتم الانسلاخ عنه باي شكل كان احنا
كمسيحيين مسموح من الزواج الطلاق
التسجيل الاولاد الى اخره من قضايانا
الشؤون الخاصه او الشؤون المدنيه ليش هاي
بس اللي تركت وطلعت من شو اسمه لانه واضح
انه كان في ضغط مجتمعي وليس ديني وليس اي
شيء اخر هو ضغط مجتمعي ما بدهم يعني
بعقلهم التفكير ما بدهم لانه بيعتقد الرجل
انه حصه الاراضي اللي عنده او او املاكه
لا يجوز ان تطلع لغريب خاصه اذا كان جوز
بنته غريب وهي قضايا على فكره من العيب
انه نفكر فيها لانه انا لما بحكي بحكي مع
بنتي بحكي معها مش مش جوز بنتي يعني انا
بحكي مع بنتي بالاخر لازم بنتي بصير زي
ابني فانت تل
جا الاسر الان لقضيه انه هو بيسجل كل ما
يملك باسماء بناته حتى ما يدخلش ناس عليه
من الورثه وهو عايش
انا بدي
يوصل صوتي حتى لو ما حلفني انا الحظ وما
وما اخذت انا حقي وحتى لو ما انطبق علي
شروط ما عندي مشكله انا بكون مبسوطه
وممنونه اذا غيري بستفيد
بتغيير القانون
فشلت المحاولات لتشريع قانون الميراث
للاردنيين المسيحيين بسبب معارضه نواب
ورجال دين واردونيين يرفضون التخلي عن
مكتسبات ذكوريه تاريخيه لمصلحه المراه في
العائله انا شخصيا
منى عيني من بكره الصبح يرجع كل اشي باسم
البنات لانه اللي بلش فيهن ابوهم انا حابب
اكمله هذا القانون تم مراجعته
ووضعه بصيغه شبه نهائيه وتم رفعه لجميع
رؤساء الطوائف في الاردن
الكنائس في الاردن نفضل ان نستخدم هذا
المصطلح ولاول مره في تاريخ الاردن توضع
مسوده قانون للميراث وهاي المسوده اعتقد
انها ستساعد في البناء والاستمرار للامام
وهذه المسوده تم نشرها في هذا الكتاب
وايضا قدمت للرؤساء مجلس رؤساء الطوائف
والمسائل الكنائس في الاردن
وهكذا استمر حرمان مسيحيات الاردن على وقع
فيتو ثلاثي غير معلن رفض كنسي جزئي عرف
ذكوري مجتمعي وحياد حكومي على الرغم من ان
هناك رغبه من اغلب الاردنيين المسيحيين في
تعديل قانون الميراث المسيحي
[موسيقى]